and we're going to not give you a
lecture with lots of data and lots of of
theory that's interesting in this area
too and we could have done that but
instead we're going to show a few slides
and we're going to try to leave more
time to interact with you around a
number of the strategic questions that
we are hearing about or that we
understand that you're facing so this is
what I'm going to do in my 10 or 15
minutes I'm going to talk in just a
dozen slides about why we think health
insurance or risk pooling is a huge
strategic opportunity for all the
countries that are here I look at some
of the big choices where your strategic
problem solving method can be applied or
and is being applied in one way or
another every day we're whatever
whatever you may be learning here you
you wrestle with these strategic choices
in your jobs speak a bit about what some
of the challenges and solutions might be
around health financing and insurance
mentioned a couple of the more promising
experiences that are occurring right now
there is an important process of
experimentation and a lot of of
information is being generated that can
be revealing and helpful to you and then
put out some some questions and I think
that it's maybe it's just a lucky
coincidence but it it struck me as I was
preparing for this talk that we had here
among the five delegations to countries
Ghana and Rwanda among the low-income
developing countries that have been the
boldest and have gone the farthest in
experimenting with health insurance
Ethiopia and and Liberia perhaps working
in this area thinking about how to go
forward maybe some questions and some
issues that you have where your
colleagues from Ghana and from Rwanda
can can provide some some lessons and I
know in Mexico having worked there and
Dave having worked there as well that
Mexico has been wrestling for many years
with the questions of health insurance
and and covered so called universal
coverage starting from a different
historical and traditional point of view
but with some of the same issue so I
think this is a problem that unifies all
of us that brings us together just to
recall some of what Arielle Pablo's
Mendez and others presented over the
last couple of days some of the problems
in the developing country and I say in
all country health systems where risk
pooling and insurance can be seen as
part of the response
first of all in many cases most cases
government revenues historically have
been channeled exclusively to government
health services the government collects
the money it then distributes it
strictly to public sector providers
salaried doctors whole series of
expenditures within the public system
this creates a certain number of
opportunities but also some problems
including the fact that from the
patient's point of view there may not be
a choice of providers there may not be
the the competitive pressures or the
incentives for good performance we were
talking over lunch Mexico I was
listening to a very interesting
discussion between Mexico and Rwanda
about pay for performance and how to
within within what's essentially a
public system with public money and
public provision how to try to somehow
incentivized higher-quality performance
and even some mention that in Mexico
separating the paying from the providing
side of the equation has been part of
what Mexico has been trying to do that
in a way is setting up some of the
dynamics that we see with most insurance
systems thirdly in these exclusively
public collection public provision
systems there's no opportunity for the
private providers these may be NGOs
religious organizations or for-profit
providers to participate and actually be
a part of the challenge of providing the
essential services to low-income
families to help achieve the national
health goals to help achieve the
Millennium Development Goals and yet we
know that in many of the countries here
today
and all around the world as important as
the government is in delivering health
services there are there's just a rich
array of private providers out there in
almost every country sometimes the
government pays attention sometimes it
doesn't sometimes it knows what's going
on or doesn't but this is a tremendous
asset which governments often don't
harness in order to achieve national
health goals insurance may be part of
the answer there and secondly
everybody's been talking about this
issue of out-of-pocket expenditure and
the it's almost become the evils of
out-of-pocket expenditure I think there
may be some good things about it but
largely it's been characterized by by
the speaker so far as the big problem
that needs to be addressed because
indeed it does expose people to
catastrophic expenditure when they're
not covered by some kind of risk pooling
arrangement they have to pay for quite
costly medical expenditures and
typically in these kinds of systems the
the I think somebody yesterday was
talking about benefit incidents looking
at really where the government is
actually spending its money I mean if
that was you and remarking that even in
these fairly public systems devoted to
helping the poor it tends to be the
better off segments of the population
they capture a lot of that public
expenditure the incidence of public
expenditure and what happens with the
lack of out-of-pocket is that for
households pay a large amount in
absolute terms but certainly as a
percentage of their income it's almost
always larger than the share of income
for the wealthier
what did you say quintiles I think you
were talking in terms of fifths of the
population and you saw this yesterday
this slide that Arielle put up I'm not
going to run through it again but I
think as he characterized it as
imperfect as these data are and I
wouldn't get carried away by this one or
the next one that I'm going to show you
because a lot more work needs to be done
the the kind of the broad color-coded
goal here over time of having more
health insurance is to turn more of
these light blues and whatever basically
the lighter the very light blue and the
and the medium blue to turn it black
because black here is good black here
means
lower level of out-of-pocket expenditure
the inverse is higher levels of health
insurance coverage this was the other
slide I think that Arielle showed it's a
little counterintuitive here because we
get the same countries in black both but
in both senses but in both of them but
here this is the inverse these are the
countries where at least the ILO
according to its data is saying that
there is a high degree in the darker
shaded countries a higher degree of
coverage and I would have thought
where's the Rwanda delegation here over
there I would have said I know Rwanda is
a small country right up there but it
should be black I think because you were
just telling me that everyone and I have
some slides actually later on just one
slide showing the coverage is very very
high now in Rwanda through its health
insurance system and I think Ghana also
through the NH is what about 60% of the
population I believe is covered now and
there's an ambition to go much higher so
I think this map is already out of date
there are two outstanding African
countries and I think Mexico that's
probably fair Mexico has a high degree
of coverage especially through through
Social Security so this is the central
thesis that I'm putting out there that
we can debate it's it's not without its
controversy but this is the strategic
the grand strategic opportunity that I'm
putting out there for you to consider
which is that health insurance risk
pooling of one kind or another and there
are many different variants on how to do
health insurance and risk pooling that
it drives a whole series of changes
throughout the the the that's the system
that have an impact on health status and
that have an impact on the rest of the
dynamics of the health system that is
maybe a bit of a bias of somebody like
myself who's an economist but I think
that there's a lot of evidence that
money here and the way in which funds
are collected the kind of protection
that's and risk risk sharing that's
that's driven or that's afforded through
health insurance it actually has a whole
series of concatenating or repercussions
throughout the health system some of the
I think many of them very positive some
of them perhaps that could be a negative
and that need to be managed but that
it's a very powerful very powerful
instrument for driving change in health
systems and whether you want to look at
the impact that it has on the financial
protection and the health of the
population or the catalytic changes in
the systems itself that it's a very very
powerful driver and one which needs to
be very carefully designed carefully
managed in order to achieve the positive
impacts that it can bring and in order
to mitigate or avoid some of the
downsides and their downsides to every
every policy change whatever might be
its upsides but reducing the
out-of-pocket expenditures and this risk
of catastrophic expenditure which drives
families into bankruptcy or into poverty
is certainly one of the very powerful
dimensions of this using health
insurance in a very carefully designed
way to increase utilization of health
services and hopefully health services
that really make a difference to health
outcomes I think again over lunch in
with the Rwanda colleagues there was a
lot of mention I believe you mentioned
that you you noticed in your own
practice that with the advent of health
insurance or the expansion that the
numbers of people coming in and
demanding services had gone up to fold
or to it you said from 40 patients you
gave the example of 50 we would show up
now and you attributed a lot of that to
the financial security that came out of
health insurance of course the next
question is what are they coming in for
what types of health issues are they
coming for not that all of them are not
valid health issues but in terms of some
of Rwanda is basic health goals around
reducing maternal mortality or child
child illness and child mortality
infectious disease are people coming in
and demanding and receiving good quality
services to deal with those health
problems that the country sees as being
central in terms of the catalytic
changes in health systems we can talk
about that during the discussion period
but it because of the way in which
insurance allows for a separation of
provision and an
financing or purchasing and creating
what what I call here a platform for
strategic purchasing there are a whole
series of things that can be done in
terms of trying to achieve national
health goals it can give patients more
of a choice of their provider it can
bring in private NGO and other non-state
providers in a way that wouldn't be
possible otherwise it can be targeted
toward essential services that have a
large health gain behind them certainly
can be used also to try to promote the
equity objectives that governments see
as part of their responsibility to try
to preferentially serve the needs of
those who are most disadvantaged it can
certainly incentivize quality and we
talked about that a bit over lunch the
Rwanda example may not be easy to
translate into Mexico there may be
special reasons why it can't just be
carried and plopped down in in one of
the one of the states in Mexico but
there may be some ideas there that you
can grasp that can be useful and
certainly in to the extent that as I say
here money follows the patient
expressing both the the demand or the
need of the patient the opportunity or
the the the stimulus to make providers
accountable to patients for what they do
in terms of timeliness and quality and
other things like that as well as
outcomes insurance may be a very
important part of the answer in terms of
the changes and the choices this is a
very stylized
look at how health financing and health
insurance evolves over time I think
there was another version of this shown
by arielle yesterday but this is an
adapted version of it if you compare a
number of the countries here today which
have modest incomes per capita say 500
to $1,000 per capita which i think is
the case of many of the african
countries here a relatively small share
of GDP or of national wealth going into
health around 4 to 6 percent typically
so this these boxes ought to be smaller
in volume than the ones on the right
because as Ari
say yesterday as countries economies
grow the share of national wealth which
goes to health tends to rise over time
the sort of iron law that he showed with
those graphs yesterday but typically
it's the out-of-pocket expenditure that
predominates the government is a large
financier and then you tend to have
smaller amounts of either social health
insurance where the I think this is the
Mexico experience covering about half of
the population where payroll taxes are
used both employee and employer taxes
are put into a pool and cover those who
actually contribute maybe not all
population but you have this as an
important way of pooling risk for a part
of the population it tends not to
necessarily be a universal system in
most developing countries with a few
exceptions like Colombia and and yeah I
guess Colombia is the one that I would
say right now and then you have the
community health insurance using local
mechanisms for collecting and often
retaining at local level premiums
sometimes subsidized by the government
in order to again pool risks but
typically across a smaller population
group but where this would be for most
of you here what are the choices you
face going forward typically as you move
toward health insurance and risk pooling
the share of out-of-pocket expenditure
goes down dramatically private health
insurance may come in in a in a modest
or a larger way but in most OECD
countries in most developed countries
private insurance tends to be small and
supplementary to the larger national
systems which tend to be either on the
national health service model along the
lines of what was developed in Britain
after the Second World War I believe
that one of the speakers yesterday
referred to beverage and the national
health system and then there's the
tradition of the social health insurance
models which much of Latin America has
picked up over the last century but I
think in many ways the historical
antecedents there come out of Germany
out of the Bismarck in period at the end
of the nineteenth century and that model
based on way wage taxes has been picked
up in an
number of the European countries such as
the Netherlands and a few others and
these pentas tends to be a choice rather
than a both it's an either-or and that's
been historically the pattern that
doesn't mean that the countries that you
come from may develop some different
system or some hybrid but those are
typically the models that countries have
moved toward over the last century
century an hour and a half and as I said
up here a much larger share of national
wealth which is also growing fight by by
definition going into the health sector
so the choices facing low-income
countries and I would say middle-income
countries like Mexico Mexico's typically
classified by the International Monetary
Fund and the World Bank as a
middle-income very solidly middle-income
country with per capita income perhaps
five to ten times what it is in many of
the other countries here today but still
I would say in general the the questions
tend to break down into these three
areas first of all are we ready for
social health insurance is there the
political momentum because this is not
just a technical decision this is very
much a political decision I was hearing
again from Rwanda I'm sorry if I keep
mentioning Rwanda but there are some
historical circumstances some of them
not very pleasant in the in the
country's history over a decade or more
ago that perhaps the the the the
positive side of that is that it's led
to a very strong political consensus and
political will to deal with some of
these issues like health insurance so
each country faces a different set of
historical and political antecedents but
there has to be at least a conversation
and a decision at a high level to move
toward this because it's not just a
health problem this is a this is an
issue that concerns the whole ministries
of Finance within government tend to and
ought to pay a lot of attention to what
happens in health insurance i husband
have a big impact on employment if you
use wage taxes it has many many effects
and of course it has a very large impact
on the whole medical care sector and
there are a lot of interest vested
interests that may or may not want to
see the kinds of changes toward health
insurance not everyone
will necessarily benefit from the
creation of a national health insurance
of one kind or another secondly what
kind of system to you or do we want to
pursue in the long run and it tends to
break down into three key areas where is
the money going to come from what's the
source of revenues is it going to be
general taxes these wage taxes local
premiums paid out of pocket at least to
finance a part of it
what's the mix where's the money going
to come from and how is it going to be
pooled together secondly how many
purchasers and what type of purchasers
are we going to have in the German
system it's a decentralized multi payer
system it's not a single government it's
not the German government collects these
wage taxes and pays all providers it's
it's a it's a decentralized sub
nationalized system with a number of
different purchasers they may compete
they may not compete so that's another
big issue and then the third one is who
in this kind of system is eligible to
provide the health services is is this
going to be a publicly delivered system
a mixed system predominantly private a
lot depends on the starting point for
each country and again these political
choices and as I said earlier at least
to stylize the choices that you face
looking at what's happened historically
not that you have to be a prisoner of of
history here by any means but there are
the national health system or national
health service type approaches using
tending to use general non earmarked
taxes or revenues a largely public
provision that's the UK system then of
course the social health insurance model
that I mentioned before I referred to to
Germany but it's also the system that
Korea very consciously copied about 25
years ago and now has a very in some
ways a very successful health insurance
system in many ways it was the
inspiration for what's happened in
Colombia over the last 15 years as the
country perhaps in Latin America that's
gone the furthest with social health
insurance and I say half of Mexico
because I believe through the two big
social security institutions in Mexico
about half that population is covered
but still there's this anguish concern
what about the other 50% what what kind
of service do they get and is it fair
are they getting good quality services
how do we improve the the protection and
the health services for the other 50%
and then finally you have some private
insurance options and and the US and and
Brazil to a certain extent Switzerland
to a certain extent use certain forms of
private health insurance it also has a
certain number of advantages but it also
has a number of disadvantages certainly
the ability to achieve the kind of
universal coverage that's implicit in
what many countries here want to do
would suggest that the approaches under
private health insurance I have some
very serious drawbacks so the other big
question first you have to ask the
question where do you where do you want
to end up what kind of a health
insurance systems you want to have ten
years 20 years from now I don't know if
that's the most of your problem solving
was one two three years so and that may
be the the political lifetime of many of
the policy makers that you know in your
countries and that we know in ours
moving to a to a large health insurance
system is almost certainly going to take
more than three years so maybe in terms
of the methodology we're thought
yesterday it's also important to think
in terms of stages and and some
intermediate milestones along the way
not that we can ever predict exactly how
these things are going to evolve so
adaptation and adjustment are also
important but the other question is how
do we get from where we are today to
where we need to go with health
insurance and I think that the most
important sort of lesson that's been
learned there is that you can end up in
almost any number of places from
whatever your starting point is today if
you know where you want to go but it
makes sense to try to build on what is
on what is out there already because
where there are community health
insurance schemes like in like in Rwanda
or social health insurance schemes as in
other countries it's easiest to build on
them then there's the question of the
the scope and the pace with which you
move and there are options you can go
slowly and
and coverage very gradually that may
risk some type of political reversal you
can also go for the big bang and try to
change things very rapidly that can be
messy but it also gets you there faster
and then you can sort out the other
issues that arise under those
circumstances there's also the question
of the affordability of what you want to
guarantee as the benefits package that
you're going to cover and this is where
a number of countries have really run
afoul and I'm not just talking about
low-income countries I'm thinking for
example of the Czech Republic after the
liberalisation there in the early 1990s
when a very generous health insurance
package which was paid to doctors on a
fee-for-service basis very quickly
bankrupt at the Czech health insurance
system which was paid out of wage taxes
so the size of the benefits package and
how you pay for it are very very
important and then there's the issue of
whether this is going to be done largely
with domestic resources or whether
there'll be a mix of domestic and
external support in terms of some of the
stumbling blocks I mentioned them
earlier so I won't go through them in
any great detail but again that's the
trilogy that I would suggest you think
about revenues the benefits package and
the issue of the payment system that
underlies it because each one of those
can either make a health insurance
system sink or swim and as there there
there are there there are many ways that
health insurance system can come
crumbling down many many ways it's not
easy and it's it's worth being vigilant
and thinking through all of these risks
as you go forward in terms of solutions
again there isn't time to go through
them all we can pick them up in the
discussion but whether it's in the
revenue area the benefits package or
payment systems there are solutions
which have been developed and
implemented and have worked well in
other countries so my suggestion without
going through each one of these is your
country is unique it can't necessarily
assume that what happens somewhere else
will be applicable but it's worth
learning the lessons of what other
countries are doing and in that sense
again it's great that Ghana and
Rwanda are here if there were more time
Betsy we could almost have an entire
week just talking about how to reform
health financing and and getting the
different countries to talk to one
another it would probably be a lot more
worthwhile than listening to me
blabber on about what I know because the
each country here telling each other
about its experience could probably
maximize the learning and the ability to
formulate responses um
I say that there's not if this is not a
blank slate and I think it's important
that among the low income countries that
have really advanced dramatically in
this area two of them are here in the
room really two of the outstanding
examples that we in results for
development when we've documented
innovations in health finance we
constantly come back to Robert to Ghana
and Rwanda so I feel very honored that
I'm here this week with those two
countries because they really are the
pioneers Ghana with its national health
insurance system Rwanda building up on
the mutual the small local local locally
sort of autonomous systems which have
been brought together in and woven
together in a national system how they
started small and got big perhaps they
can tell us about in the discussion but
there are also other countries that are
not here Nigeria which has some very
interesting experiments right now using
HMOs health maintenance organizations
India which is a itself a vast
laboratory for experimentation in in
health finance it's unbelievable it's
like a continent or or or a planet unto
itself when it comes to things that are
going on right now in the health
insurance area we can't we can't keep
track of them all we've been trying to
monitor them but there are a huge number
of things going on there and I did want
to mention although Mexico is a
middle-income country I put it here at
the end because Mexico under its recent
health minister Julio Frank has made a
very bold move to create a kind of
insurance for the 50 percent who are
still not covered by Social Security
whether it's the perfect solution I know
that from talking to the Mexican
delegation they're struggling with how
to improve the use of this people's
insurance that's what the gurukul are
means in Spanish it's not the the story
is
at its end it's perhaps at its middle or
its beginning but I know this is
something you're working very hard on
this was the Ghana system I'm not going
to run through this but Ghana collects
the money up here at the top through a
number of different channels including
wage taxes and value-added tax so it's a
mix of general taxation or or at least
taxation on consumption across the board
and individual wage taxes it also has
small user fees and it also draws in
premiums that are collected through
other other sources and then it it uses
it to allow patients to go to a mix of
public and private health facilities in
the case of Rwanda I said I would at
least show one picture it looks like I
need to add another another dot
somewhere up here because you were
saying now that Rwanda is up to 95
percent or 97 percent coverage but this
is this is almost unprecedented if it's
true if it can be verified and if this
is really leading to the kind of social
protection or financial protection that
health insurance can give this is quite
a remarkable expansion of the insurance
in Rwanda in terms of some of the
lessons learned just to finish up these
are broad generalizations each one can
be questioned and challenged I would do
the same but certainly what you start
with the voluntary and the
community-based financing systems can
help to build confidence in the larger
prepaid schemes as people get used to to
participating and to contributing
something I think it's two dollars per
person in Rwanda it's not a huge amount
of money although for some households
that might be considerable this is a way
to build public interest and support the
key thing is to just to pool full risks
whether it's through the social health
insurance approach or the national
health system approach may be of less
importance than the political decision
to move to this type of universal
coverage and to go at it in a systematic
problem-solving way because problems
will come up along the along the journey
no matter how well you plan ahead of
time as I said earlier my three little
make sure the benefits package the
revenue collection and the payment are
very carefully examined and and managed
because that's where these systems tend
to rise or fall the political commitment
that's that's very clear but also the
management and administrative capacity
to support these systems that's what
many of you here are so good at
evaluated each stage and keep adapting
and don't forget that overall as Arielle
said yesterday if the country's economy
is not growing it's very hard to put any
type of a health insurance system in
place I know you're not the ministers of
finance or economy but it does matter so
this is where I'm finishing just with
some questions that we could take up in
the discussion for Ghana and Rwanda that
have already traveled far with this
maybe you could talk a little bit about
the most difficult problems we know
you've done a lot of good things but
what are the big problems you face can
you can you can you can you share with
us what what worries you about the
progress you've made and whether there
may be some backsliding and whether
there's some new issues which have come
up and how are you dealing with those
for countries like Ethiopia and Liberia
that are here what are your plans in the
health insurance area where is the
country going with this and what are the
big questions and worries you have or
perhaps the others can can be helpful
and then I say here this is this was
written I think before I had lunch today
and I wrote down are there lessons from
the reform of the social health
insurance system and the saguru popular
in Mexico that could be useful for the
African countries what I heard over
lunch was the reverse
I heard Mexico mostly listening to
Rwanda and trying to get some clear
ideas about how to put in place this
performance-based financing so it's
really a two-way street here and finally
just to end what can yell faculty and
external partners like ourselves do to
help you to try to deal with some of
these problems because that's our job
that's what we're here for
to learn together with you and to try to
advance your agenda thank you